I think that there's definitely like a
phase shift that's happening where I
mean I'm fortunate my dad's much older
and so he raised me to be like pull
yourself up by the bootstraps but
there's a whole generation of kids that
were raised with a totally different
attitude at NYU uh there's a hotline on
the ID cards I believe it's essentially
like an unoffended hotline what is this
thing it's a hotline that was set up by
the school where it's on the back of our
ideas the effect is watch what you say
because the kids around you are
deputized essentially and I think we
used to acknowledge that there's no one
Arbiter of Truth and there's no like one
gatekeeper that can say this is fact and
this is fiction and we've drifted so far
away from the idea that we need to let
people duke it out and and have
conversations all right guys bang bang
I've got Ricky here with me Ricky I
thought a great place to start given
kind of your past couple of years uh and
your rise in popularity on the internet
and in many different uh political
circles was to talk about this idea of a
college Exodus and I've read a number of
different versions where you are sitting
in college all of a sudden at home and
realized like maybe this isn't worth it
talk a little bit about that experience
and kind of what was going on during the
two-year pandemic uh while still in
college
yeah so I was a sophomore I guess when
the pandemic started and it was the
spring semester in my sophomore year I
had gone to NYU with the expectation
that I'd be going to law school and I
got to school and I was like hiding my
Jordan Peterson books under my bed and
just kind of keeping my head down to
um hopefully achieve academically and
just kind of get to the next thing and
then the pandemic happened and I was in
lockdown I was in LA living with my mom
and she was watching me do zoom and just
be like miserable and then NYU increased
tuition beyond the rate of inflation at
the time which was insane to me
um and so she said I'll help you get
through one semester of a leave of
absence just do something cool do
something productive and then you can go
back and then of course the world never
got normal and at the same time I was
just reading and doing my thing and
learning in the way that I wanted to
learn I think which was
um very liberating for me rather than
just having a syllabus that a professor
decided
um on my behalf and so that turned into
just sending a few op-eds here and there
and then it just kind of snowballed and
all of a sudden now here I am doing
journalism full-time
um I don't think that I'll be going back
to school
um it's possible I got into Columbia
recently and I might end up doing that
part time but
um by and large I think my story is kind
of similar to a lot of people who were
just in the achievement Loop and then
pulled out and realized like oh I'm not
doing what I love and I was fortunate
that I was young enough that that
happened at a point where like I hadn't
already invested in LSAT prep and all
that time and so I could kind of just
pull the plug and reorient and think
leads worked out so yeah so when you
think of the zoom University which is a
hilarious name for this whole phenomenon
you're there on Zoom attending class but
NYU then increases the tuition at a
faster Pace than inflation what was
their logic for doing
um I think they just did the tuition
increase that they had scheduled um and
it's I mean it's one of the most
expensive schools in the country in the
first place which I went in with the
understanding that that was the case
it's New York City the cost of living is
obviously enormous and living there is
and with a dorm room like I just
accepted that fact but then when you
don't even have the benefit of that and
the school thinks that they're giving
you an adequate enough education just I
mean I was also it was like 5 a.m in
California and I'm in uh like Middle
Ages class for my history major and none
of the kids are showing up everyone's
cameras off if they even do like the
morale was super low the standards were
going down we recently had a big scandal
at NYU they fired a organic chemistry
professor for being too hard which is
pretty ironic considering organic
chemistry at the class you're meant to
take to figure out if you're you have
what it takes to be a doctor and so
um I just generally I saw the quality of
Education decline the lack of in-person
connection like one of the biggest
things for me was meeting professors and
like networking and kind of being a part
of the community there and so it just
wasn't serving me at the time and
thankfully
um I had the guts to actually leave
so when you think about uh people being
fired for being too hard of a professor
well I saw the headline I literally just
laughed I was like this has got to be a
[ __ ] joke uh what happened there or
what is the conversation among the
people who went to NYU are most of the
students like yeah that should have
happened or are they like this is
ridiculous and and they feel bad for the
professor like what's going on
I feel like a lot of people didn't
really investigate it very deeply I've
talked to some of my friends that went
there and most of them are like yeah
well those course evaluations were
really bad but essentially what happened
is there's this organic chemistry
professor this is supposed to be a
stumble class it's one of the first
things you take if you can't get through
this you probably shouldn't be entrusted
with someone's life in an operating room
and that's the whole point like you
might get a c but if you get through
then awesome and there's this one like
old I think it was 84
um he had he's he wrote the textbook for
the past he had been at Princeton before
and then he was on a year-over-year
um like part-time basis as a professor
in semi-retirement at NYU and kids in
the class circulated a petition saying
he's too hard he's not helping us he's
not telling us like how to get to the
next step in um like there's an
expectation with my generation that a
professor will tell you how to read the
essay or how to study for the test and
then you just are told what to do and do
it and get an A and he wasn't doing that
he hadn't changed his standards he's
taught in the field for like 40 years or
something crazy and the standards of
like how students are performing which
is not entirely their fault considering
some of these kids were in high school
like half of their High School
experience was in lockdown which was
unjust in the first place but there's an
expectation that you lower the standards
if kids are not doing as well and that's
obviously not the way to go if we want
to get back to where we once were but
the great inflation at NYU is like
absolutely insane like the average
grades in most courses is like an A
minus or something like that so if the
if the standard of Excellence isn't even
rewarded there weren't a pluses at NYU
like what are we really doing if
everyone is just like getting a gold
star the two things that immediately
makes me think of uh one I think part of
the petition was also like he's hurting
our chances of getting into medical
school right so like it wasn't even like
him as a teacher as much as it was like
if I get a bad grade because I'm an
idiot or because I don't do the work to
get an A in the class then somehow
that's his fault not my fault uh stuck
out to me and the second thing is uh I
don't know if you know who this is but
uh there's a gentleman named Paul Graham
he started y combinator he previously
sold a company uh in the tech industry
um and he essentially has an
apprenticeship for Founders and it's
become uh incredibly lucrative for him
and his team but also it has produced
companies like Airbnb and Dropbox and
many other large tech companies and he
wrote a a piece one time that said most
people need to learn how to unlearn what
they got in the education system and his
whole point was people would show up to
Why combinator and they'd be like okay
what do I do to raise my first round of
funding okay now that I did that like
what do I do to do the second thing it's
very similar like how do I write the
essay what are the questions that are
going to be on the test so that I can
pass and he's like no no no like what
you need to do is you need to build a
product that people like and then you
cannot raise whatever money you want you
can do you know it's like a different
game and it sounds like maybe the
students in college today that's kind of
lost to them in some way
yeah totally I mean I think it's
um it goes back to like the way that we
were raised in childhood in my opinion
where like everything is done for you
your parents are very engaged um like
they're they're wiping the germs off of
everything and then you don't really
develop the immune system sort of
analogy where like for as like so many
of our parents were getting us to sports
games and helping us get into college
with these essays and like we've we've
had our hands held and then they're
older professors who don't want to
continue to do that like this guy but
then there's also younger professors who
know now like the asylums are the sorry
the inmates are running the asylums here
a little bit and essentially like these
these younger professors don't want bad
uh recommendations from their students
we do these course evaluations that NYU
puts out all the time and um like if
you're getting tanked in your in your
course evaluations as a young Professor
who wants to continue to work at NYU
then you better just give kids A's
because that's the way to get the five
stars from all of them and so I think
that there's
um definitely like a phase shift that's
happening where I mean I'm fortunate my
dad's much older and so he kind of
raised me and my mom is um from like a
kind of tough Eastern European family
and so they raised me to be like pull
yourself up by the bootstraps I'm not
gonna cuddle you and hold your hand the
whole way through like you get yourself
to where you're going to go but there's
a whole generation of kids that were
raised with a totally different attitude
and now the the new generation of
professors are saying well this is what
I have to do to succeed and to get the
five-star evaluations
at NYU uh there's a hotline on the ID
cards I believe uh it's essentially like
an I'm offended hotline what is this
thing yeah so um it's the I think it's
the bias response hotline is what it's
called and um I actually brought that up
I was on Bill Myers show recently and I
told him about that
and I just brought it up as an anecdote
because I've known it about it for all
this time and he really like went in on
it
um but essentially it's a hotline that
was set up by the school
um like within the last decade where
it's on the back of our ideas it's
literally like the like the 911 number
the Student Health Center the campus
police like the really important things
that you need to be a student at NYU and
then also on the back is this bias
response number which
um is supposed to be like obviously I
want to Steel Man it and say that of
course like there are things that
shouldn't happen on college campuses and
there can be bias incident incidents and
you know the school has every right to
make sure that that's seen through but
essentially there's this like hotline
phone number where rather than go to
like a dean and say hey this thing
happened to me like it's essentially a
snitch culture and so I brought that up
on MAR and then later wrote an article
about it because I the more I went
through nyu's original preliminary
report about how it how well it had
worked they like separated things out
between like actual egregious like
offense that someone could get kicked
out for
um something that maybe just gets them
like a little discipline and then
something that just doesn't really rise
to that level which they gave the
example of like cultural appropriation
or something like that so basically just
that I'm offended and you didn't do
anything wrong to me but I don't like
what you said sort of level of entry and
the majority were in the latter
um so it's essentially just telling
people I mean it has a chilling effect
that's on the um the back of our cards
it's on the back of the Stalls and the
bathrooms in the library often they put
like signs up so everyone knows and the
idea is like I mean I don't think it's
the intention but the effect is watch
what you say because the kids around you
are deputized essentially and
um I I mean I just found it to be very
creepy and very weird and I just don't
think a hotline is the answer to
interpersonal problems it feels like the
people who are relying on the hotline
are going to get metaphorically punched
in the face when they walk out into the
real world and someone says something
mean to them uh because they don't have
a hotline to call like you know you can
imagine like who do you call in the real
world when you're like that person
offended me uh some people do call the
police as we've seen uh but for the most
part like you're kind of you know out of
luck and so I don't know it does feel
like there's a little bit of coddling
going on there another another example
of this is uh the professors I think
you've mentioned in the past uh they
have to issue trigger warnings before
they say certain things in the classroom
yeah that's happening
um I think for the majority of the
classes that I've been in if I had one
of those it would just be on the
syllabus which at least it's not like
they're verbally saying it but um I've
heard more and more reports of like
literal law school students getting
trigger warnings for case content which
if you need a trigger warning to be like
doing the the um like precursor function
of being a lawyer and dealing with the
sometimes awful things that lawyers are
dealing with that's
so like I I can't even imagine how
unprepared this next generation of
people going into these professions are
going to be like for example
um there have been a ton of reports of
law school professors who are being
asked to either issue a trigger warning
or potentially remove
um like rape cases which I mean the
world is the world of course that's an
awful thing but if you want somebody to
be able to go out and argue on behalf of
justice and defend somebody or or put a
bad person behind bars then they need to
understand what the bad thing is so I
mean it's it's one thing when it's an
undergraduate class which I roll my eyes
at it's another thing when it's a like
profession a pre-professional graduate
level course so um yeah it's that's yet
another thing that I think is very
coddling how do they issue the trigger
warning like if it's on the syllabus
does it literally say like trigger
warning you know the contents of this
syllabus May offend you or do they stand
in front of them class and be like
trigger warning or do they kind of more
aptly present These Warnings
I think there have been
um examples of both I know some
personally but they'll do like the first
day of class and say like these topics
will be addressed in this semester and
just get it out of the way other
professors will put it in like their um
their presentations or PowerPoints maybe
if they're doing something on a day that
might be disturbing to someone and then
in the syllabus it would essentially
just say like content learning and like
this this course deals with issues of X
Y and Z and you know deal with that what
you want but I think the unfortunate
thing about the trigger warnings is that
it makes the assumption that the way to
help someone with trauma is to protect
them from the source of it and of course
like over traumatizing someone is not
ever what you want to do but cognitive
behavioral therapy has shown that
essentially the best thing to get past
like PTSD like symptoms is is reasonable
exposure and to face your fears and to
actually acknowledge them and deal with
them and I think that the assumption
that kids even kids from terrible
backgrounds who have experience trauma
need to be told no you can't handle this
by a professor or that they should be
raised with the assumption that they
need to have the the jungle kind of
paved for them in that way is
um like it's just kind of just
disheartening I mean I can't even
imagine thinking like oh I have I'm I'm
worried about this content or I need to
digest this or deal with this or grapple
with this but my professor is telling me
that I can't so um I'm I'm very
concerned about it and I think it
totally flies in the face of what we
know about like cognitive behavioral
therapy entirely yeah this brings the
idea of like right think and wrong thing
which I've seen you talk about and uh
it's hilarious to me that literally it
feels like on a college campus the way
that you've described it is that there
are certain things you are allowed to
say but also certain ways to think and
if you violate that you are outcast in
some way uh or heavily incentivized to
not voice your opinion uh for fear of
violating that kind of right thing that
that is so pervasive
yeah totally I mean on so many levels
too because there's the fear of grades I
found more and more through my academic
experience that there's an expectation
or like a reward if you basically repeat
back what the professor said to them or
you you make their viewpoints
essentially be reflected in your essay I
I've seen that happen more and more and
more where there's an expected
conclusion and you can kind of tell that
professors have this like subversive
message that they're expecting to get
through to you through the course of a
semester
um but then there's also the social
repercussions too which I mean this is
happening in high school as well but I
mean everything going to college is
looking at social media and seeing
people get canceled and and people get
canned for voicing opinions sometimes
that are very very reasonable
um and so going to school leaving your
house being 18 living somewhere new
having roommates like of course you're
going to sit on your hands and not be
honest about who you you are if you feel
like you're going to be living in this
new place and totally shunned and and
miserable and canceled so um I think on
so many levels in college campuses
there's this this urge to kind of keep
quiet and I felt it and I'm really glad
that I kind of left that behind and
fortunately
um most people in my life have been
um understanding and welcoming because I
try to approach them in good faith even
if we have political differences
um so I I mean I felt it I did it I I
sat on my hands I wrote essays that I'd
look back on and probably say I don't
agree with any of that and I probably
didn't at the time that I wrote it too
which is really sad why do you think
that you wrote them it was it hey this
is what's going to get me an A and this
is going to like help me get pushed
through this system and get to law
school uh is it oh my God my you know
roommate or uh uh kind of fellow student
is gonna read it and if I don't write
this then like I'm gonna be shunned if
you had to kind of unpack uh having
written things that maybe you didn't
agree with at the time like why do you
think you did it
yeah I would say
um for me it was definitely academic
oriented like I just you know I wanted
to achieve I wanted to go to law school
I um I worked hard and I wanted my
grades to reflect that but I mean I
wouldn't I had never made like an
argument that I don't believe in but I
think that there were there were things
that were taught to me as truth or fact
from time to time that I didn't feel
like I should be challenging in the
course of an essay and I sometimes
looking back I like I know some of the
professors still who actually are they
might not agree with me but they're
supportive of me and we we we're still
in touch and they know what I'm doing in
writing and had I kind of put myself out
there and taken that risk I don't think
I would have been batted down as
aggressively as I expected but then
again there are also professors who are
just like they clearly have their
ideology and they and they want you to
walk away with little nugget of their
knowledge that they feel they have and
it's just disappointing to me that by
large I would know the political
orientations of almost every single one
of my professors even if it wasn't
relevant to the course
um and so yeah that was just kind of
disheartening but I wouldn't have I
didn't like write a thesis that I don't
agree with or present it as my own idea
but I like at the time I told myself
like oh I'm just arguing like what this
piece is arguing or I'm I'm making that
point which was a good mental exercise
in a sense but
um it's still like I look back and I'm
like darn but I think every other kid in
college is essentially doing that yeah
it's kind of crazy you also mentioned uh
putting Jordan Peterson's books under
your bed uh same exact you know kind of
pressures of like somebody walks in my
dorm room or uh into my place and if
they see that I have a Jordan Peterson
book here they're going to think that
I'm some you know vicious monster that
may lash out and they'll have to call
the bias hotline or something else
yeah I mean it was just like I I mean I
don't like to bring politics into
friendships
um I generally try not to even though
I'm a very political person but the
reason that I was doing that was like I
mean I have roommates and they're all
lovely and I'm still friends with all
them and it probably would have been
totally fine
um but there are some very aggressively
political people at NYU and I just
thought you know it's just not worth it
I don't I don't need to
um even though obviously like here I am
in front of my bookshelves now and
that's like a very
um my politics are a very important part
of who I am but um yeah I just it was a
it was a social pressure to just not
pick any fights or have any anyone come
and say like you're a terrible person or
um I mean obviously Jordan Peterson just
recently was tart and feathered for
being like essentially wanting to put
women back in 1950s gender roles by
Olivia Wilde who made a whole movie
based off of a misunderstanding of what
he has said and advocated for and so I
think there's that bad face
interpretations that I grew up seeing
all the time on social media and
I didn't want that to happen to me I
just wanted to have friends in Coast by
and get as and then go to law school
which was I'm so thankful that that is a
old version of myself because actually
being who I am and saying what I mean
has been so much more fruitful yeah uh
let's talk about the Olivia Wilde and
the Jordan Peterson stuff so my
understanding is that Jordan Peterson
been living his life doing his thing uh
Olivia Wilde created a movie uh was
recently doing some of the press to kind
of build up you know uh support and
interest in the movie was asked about
one of the main characters and she
essentially said yeah that character was
rooted in or inspired by Jordan Peterson
but then she went on to say that he is
the leader of the incels uh I may be
dating myself I didn't know what that
was I had to go Google and was like okay
um and he was asked about it I think I'm
and Piers Morgan or maybe one of the
other shows and he actually got pretty
emotional
um and he basically was like look you
know I'm trying to speak directly to
young men who uh are depressed who feel
lonely who you know are in kind of a bad
place in their life uh I don't see the
connection was essentially what he said
I guess it's like my understanding of
the situation correct to start with and
then like how did you think about this
back and forth between two people who
you know don't quite seem to cross paths
a lot uh from what we can tell from the
outside
yeah I mean I think her characterization
of him was completely unfair like she
made the she said he was he was like the
pseudo-intellectual leader of the insom
movement and that he justifies their
worldview wherein uh men are entitled to
sex from women and just painted this
hideous picture of him and then made
this whole film based on the premise
that there's this cult leader who's
evidently Peterson who is making this
like experimental little world where
women are back in the 1950s roles and
oppressed and he teared up actually on
Piers Morgan's podcast which a lot of
people were dunking on him for but I
just I mean it's such a gross
mischaracterization of who he is and
what he says I don't agree with
everything that he says I don't think I
should agree with anything that
everything that anyone in the public
world says because I'm a different
person but he I felt the need to like
stick up for him a little bit because I
am I read his books when I was going to
college and I continued to be a fan of
his I found so much in his lectures that
have been fruitful and meaningful and
empowering I give him impart credit for
when I was 20 being an influence of just
like do your thing and actually be you
and work hard and you'll be rewarded and
that's why I'm not just in the feedback
loop of the achievement Loop right now
but I I spoke out because I'm a young
woman who has never really felt either
that his advice is specifically gendered
like I've never heard him say something
that I'm like oh that's clearly Just For
Men sometimes they'll speak directly to
men or directly to women's issues but
like his general advice is just for
people looking to assume some
responsibility do their thing be a
competent human being in the world and
um kind of buck the victim mentality and
just kind of do what you can for
yourself and I think that the it's like
very old classic wisdom I don't think
it's rocket science or something totally
new and shocking it's just classic
advice and so to hear that somehow
because young men have gravitated to him
more that's a bad thing or that that
must mean that it's like a zero-sum game
wherein like lifting young men up is
pushing young women down to me is just
the opposite of what my experience with
him has been so it's it was an
interesting kind of cultural moment to
watch because I don't even know like
where Olivia Wilde came from with this
but um it's it's it's always interesting
to see that is what people think when
they see the Jordan Peterson book which
no wonder it was under my bed because if
I'm like a gatekeeper to the uh
misogynistic in cell culture then I mean
no wonder people would want to cancel me
yeah it is very interesting how uh you
mentioned Zero Sum and I don't really I
haven't thought enough about it to have
like a fully formed view but it feels
like the people who have been labeled as
misogynistic in terms of putting content
out on the internet now there are
definitely misogynists there are
definitely people who say dumb stuff do
dumb stuff and and I think those people
are pretty easily identified and uh kind
of outcast or shunned and uh rightfully
so for the people who do that stuff but
what has become now uh kind of a common
Playbook or a tactic is anyone who is
speaking to uh really mental health
issues and loneliness and these other
things that uh are very well documented
both in the scientific community and the
psychological Community uh but also in
just kind of the mainstream press they
are labeled as misogynistic because of
who gravitates to their message and what
fascinates me about this is when you ask
them so literally if you go and you ask
them hey somebody said X their responses
they sure sound pretty uh common sense
they sure sound like oh wait the way
that this person thinks about what
they're doing is something that actually
most parents would want their kids to
have right they would want to see this
and so like what do you think is the
disconnection here is it just people see
like a a clip or they see like one piece
of it and then they make a bunch of
judgments and it usually is the most
extreme version of them is it they don't
care do they just need an enemy to point
at like what's going on why is it that
the people who are actually in the
communities or the people who are
providing the information think one
thing and the people on the outside have
like almost a 180 degree different view
of what's going on this episode is
brought to you by eight sleep good sleep
is a game changer and the eight sleep
pod is the best sleep machine I sleep on
it every single night a great night of
sleep allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as high hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself innate sleep you can
go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founders to let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
pump go get yourself an eight sleep pod
and get a better night of sleep yeah I
mean I think the seeing Clips out of
context thing is certainly at play here
I mean the more time you spend saying
something publicly the more stupid
things that you're just going to say
inevitably and so I think every like
public figure probably has a reel of
stuff that just wouldn't be great if you
put it all together and then that became
like the kind of face of your brand for
a ton of people in the population and I
think that was in part at play with the
Peterson thing I think there's also just
this like
this really sad sense in our culture
that like statistically boys are
struggling everyone's struggling right
now there are like men are falling
behind in education and
um their suicide rates are going up so
are girls as well but I think there's
there's a sad assumption for some reason
that specifically ends up getting
Peterson like tart and feathered is just
because he he's speaking to issues
sometimes that do that do pertain more
to men or not necessarily but he has
spoken out about like the ways in which
men are falling behind or gender
differences which is something that I
think you should be allowed to
acknowledge but there's this sense that
you know we have girl power and you can
do it and like be a girl boss and that's
all great whatever do your thing but as
soon as you flip it around there's this
idea that just because you're speaking
to young men or young men are getting
empowerment from you and
um deriving it from a person like
Peterson that that somehow is anti-woman
which I think is just such a sad reflex
collection like you can be pro-woman and
pro men and just Pro people and the idea
that somehow he's like a gatekeeper to
the misogyny or like to the patriarchy
because of that is
um a really gross mischaracterization in
my opinion and I I know he gets crap
sometimes for talking about like gender
differences but I think that's actually
um acknowledging stuff that we all kind
of see with our eyes but some people
just pretend not to really think about
um and I don't know I I mean I think
there's a lot of factors at play and
then also people just love the idea of
like oh here's this he was also compared
to like red school he was like a Marvel
Nazi based character oh my cat just
walked across my bookshelves behind me
here
um
but I I think there's an idea that like
it's it's nice to have a villain it's
nice to have the bad guy that you can
um refer to and yeah I don't know it's
just really sad because to me he's very
innocuous in a lot of ways sometimes
he'll say something I'm like yeah I
don't agree with that but I mean he's
basically just giving fatherly advice to
a lot of young men and increasingly a
lot of young men don't have fathers in
the home and statistically that harms
boys far more than it does girls and so
the idea that someone kind of filling
that void and giving some old classic
wisdom and advice would be a terrible
thing it's just sad yeah what's the
difference between girl boss and alpha
male is there a difference like it feels
like those two things are trying to get
at the same concept of somebody who uh
is in charge of themselves their family
their uh their life their uh group of
friends the organization that they're
within what you know what whatever the
the kind of uh perimeter is that you
want to uh label but it feels like
really it's just modern terms for leader
uh but they've received very differently
in society it appears yeah
um yeah I mean I guess there really
isn't
actual qualities that we're describing
um except for that one is celebrated and
one is demonized but
um yeah I mean I guess I I can
understand the fact that over the past
few decades like women needed to be
promoted and and lifted up and there
we've made a lot of progress and we have
like we're we're working and doing our
own thing and we're financially
independent and we have more
opportunities and options before us than
ever before and so the idea that we did
benefit from encouragement and having
that conversation and getting there is
great but the idea that you couldn't
also have that conversation about men
and empowering men when clearly people
just in general and by and large are
disempowered in the same way
um I mean I just think it's a it's a
double standard but I can understand
like that one might be more taboo
because of the historical context
whereas the other was kind of a useful
mechanism to empower young girls to like
think that like dream big and stuff like
I mean I I guess the historical context
is also the only real difference up and
she knocked up the books
sorry so when you think about
squashing descent right when somebody
has an idea somebody has a Viewpoint and
you just constantly or after them
whether it's an online mob whether it's
in a classroom at a university or it's
just what I would consider a more
traditional cultural pressures or social
pressures uh that obviously plays into
self-censorship I have many many friends
that I am in private group chats with
who will say things and it's like wow
the difference between what you were
willing to say on uh out in public
online versus what you will say in
private is widening at an alarming rate
and I've asked them I was like hey why
don't you feel comfortable saying that
in public and it usually comes down to
two answers one is like I just don't
want to deal with the backlash I don't
want to deal with the nonsense like it's
not my uh goal nor do I enjoy waking up
every day and like going to war on the
internet right it's like that's like one
group of uh people and the other group
of people is just like uh I have career
risk I have you know some other risk
that uh I can't say it right I'm not in
a position where I can go out and say
this and not worry about what the the
reaction is do you see this among young
people as well where there's
self-censorship is not only happening
but it's becoming much much more kind of
robust and pervasive uh throughout that
generation
100 because I mean I was probably in
high school in the earliest version of
modern cancel culture started to be a
thing and and like celebrities are BD
platforms or even people at school and I
think growing up with this sense that
there there's like a public facing you
and a kitchen table kind of you um I
mean it feels like very Soviet to me
like it's it's really dystopian but
growing up in that way and feeling like
you need to develop like the the type of
person or the the set of beliefs that's
palatable to a professor or to a teacher
or
um to your Social Circle uh versus who
you actually are maybe like the context
of your family you go home and they have
a totally different set of values from
this assumed set of values with your
school is enormous and I think going
developing in that way versus a lot of
adults recently like have had to kind of
shift and uh kind of get into that
mindset
um I think there's something
very sad about growing up and being a
teenager and you're supposed to be
grappling with ideas and like messing up
that's just part of being a teenager
you're going to say stupid things and
now it's on the internet forever and
people are want to attack you for
virtually anything you say or go way
back into your uh Teenage tweets like
they did to that team Vogue editor and
so I think it's kind of short circuiting
this exploratory time when you're a
teenager and you're supposed to be like
an anarchist one day and a communist the
next day and just figuring things out
and saying stupid stuff and realizing
later that that was stupid and then
getting smarter from the process of
doing that and kids aren't really given
the freedom to do that anymore and so I
feel my generation I think is probably
most adversely impacted because we've
we've never really known anything
different and I've found since I started
speaking out I thought NYU was going to
be like the most inhospitable place for
someone like me as in your post
columnist of all things switch actually
hasn't proven to be as bad as I expected
because you have no idea when everyone's
sitting around and sitting around and
sitting on their hands and biting their
tongues that there are people around you
that either not necessarily think like
you but would respect your views but
they never get voiced they never get
aired there's just one sort of narrative
that in classrooms is allowed to thrive
and survive and then like as soon as I
just decided like screw it and I wrote
an op-ed about free speech at NYU I
could not believe the amount of people
that I knew professors that I knew Deans
that I knew of that I would never have
imagined would reach out and say hey
congratulations on this classmates
people who lived across the hall for me
and I never would have put that together
and I'm sure that none of them have put
together how many other people are more
heterodox in their Universe because they
didn't speak out and I'm not saying that
like everyone should do that obviously
if you have if you're gonna go to law
school and that's not the the right move
for you then do your thing whatever's
best but I think there's this illusion
that you're totally alone in places like
like college campuses or at like in a
progressive City when that's not
actually the case and I'm just like the
human repository for everyone's stuff
where they're like can I run an idea
past you but like don't tell anyone or
I'll get like the texts outside of group
chats of like have you thought about
this and I'm like yeah I mean you're
like I appreciate that you're coming to
me but you can also see that in front of
people because everyone's sitting on
their hands and everyone's kind of
questioning things more than you realize
that they are but it's just because
we've never kind of like broken down
that barrier that everyone's just coming
to me and saying like here's my secret
Viewpoint that I don't want everyone to
know
it's just leadership the the way that I
always come back to is uh we forget
biologically there is uh this element
that when you see someone step up into a
leadership position if if they're good
right now again there's bad leaders but
if they step up into that leadership
position uh people will follow and and
uh you see this and everything from the
military and War uh to local politics to
National politics but also in Social
Circles and I think one of the pieces of
uh The Playbook that I'll I'll uh call
out is cancel culture was winning for a
long time because everyone feared it now
all of a sudden you have people who have
learned the Playbook of when cancel
culture comes for them they just say no
I'm not canceled and what it does is it
actually uh swings the pendulum back it
gives them much more power right like
one of the things uh that I've observed
multiple times now is there have been uh
very obvious efforts to go after someone
whether it's the online mob whether it's
just a cancer culture thing what you
know sometimes they're the same
sometimes those are different
and whether it is the actual individual
themselves who stands up and says uh no
I will not apologize I think Matt Walsh
recently did this uh with some of the
the work that he was doing he did a
whole video and it's kind of dramatic
but but he basically was like no I'm not
apologizing like I am right on this I'm
convicted on this and I go away and that
gave him way more power and and it
almost uh uh reinvigorated an entire
following around his leadership on that
one issue at the same time we saw when
uh people came for Joe Rogan and was
calling him racist and all this stuff
Andrew Schultz stood up and was like
listen I don't give a [ __ ] what you guys
are saying I know this man I don't think
he's racist he's helped me drastically
in my career and blah blah you know all
this other stuff has he has you know
many people in the comedic industry a
bunch of people rallied around that and
kind of stood back up and so when we see
these examples I do wonder how much of
it is like the cancel culture was a
learned behavior and so people saw that
it worked and so then they began to
execute that Playbook over and over
again and now almost the like counter uh
you know tactic to cancel culture has
been learned and so now we just get two
groups that are gonna war with each
other uh with it being unclear whether
there's actually ever a true winner now
because both sides are armed with the
Playbook as to how to handle the
situation what do you think
yeah I think there's a Nuance between
public figures and people and their
private lives with cancel culture that
um like just the unfortunate reality is
if you're out there and in the world and
someone tries to tear you down you have
more Defenders to come by your side and
people with less to lose because they're
established
um but I would say like 100 the idea
that you don't apologize to the Mob if
you if you haven't done anything wrong I
mean if someone pulls something stupid
that you said from forever ago that was
just stupid and you just say Okay that
was stupid and move on like I think
we've learned that the apologies and the
like very clear like people just
disavowing their former selves and you
can tell that's not genuine is not the
way to go so I think the tactic of
fighting back is certainly more refined
than it was I would say for the average
Joe who might like have something happen
in a workplace or have something happen
in school the odds that people are going
to come up and stand stand by their side
when their job is at stake or when your
job could maybe be at stake by standing
up as well
um I'm I'm more dubious that on the kind
of low scale personal level that's
necessarily
um as feasible but I would say that by
and large we've learned a lot of lessons
from uh as bad as it got especially in
2020 I feel like literally everyone was
getting canceled and everyone was scared
to speak out because I felt like we were
having this like Collective social
meltdown
um but yeah I worry about like it almost
makes us kind of retreat into our own
camps and say like oh now like I'm I've
been canceled and so now I'm uncanceling
myself and I'm going to just make a
universe of people who agree with me
which I totally understand that that's
the reaction when you've been pushed out
of a universe or pushed out of like the
kind of mainstream but I think it's it's
a sad effect because we've totally lost
the ideals of free speech culture and
the ideas of like how you talk through
differences and just treat people like
human beings or even like there's
there's an interesting double standard
where I think it used to be like you
don't talk about politics at the dinner
table and that I actually think is
probably a healthy thing like maybe you
don't bring that up on the first date or
you maybe don't need to talk about it at
Thanksgiving but there's this double
standard that's come up where or even in
the workplace but now every workplace is
like espousing the same values and
there's a certain set of politics that
you can talk about and play company and
then the other side that you can't so
it's a it's a weird kind of double
standard but I do worry about
um not that I like ascribe blame to
somebody who says oh I'm gonna uncancel
myself and make my own universe and go
independent I think that's a great thing
I'm glad that that's an option for
people and that they're being supported
like there are a lot of creators that
have gone independent on substack and I
think that's great but
it's just it's disappointing that we're
kind of leaving behind all these
institutions and like
you know I'll leave like a big
publication and do my own thing and not
talk to people across the aisle like I
think it has a sad negative long-term
effect as well
I don't disagree but I also think uh
people like to tell the story that the
big institutions uh oh you know woe is
us we don't know how we found our way to
this weird place uh damn aw shucks uh we
don't like how we got here I think that
that's complete [ __ ] in many cases
uh I think it's like in very intentional
very malicious uh and you know I have
friends who work inside of some of these
organizations and left and the stories
you hear about you know uh facts being
made up uh people literally uh just
digging and digging and digging until
they can find the information they need
for their specific uh angle on a story
uh the
um uh just complete lack of what I would
consider journalistic ethics or the
pursuit of the truth and more so the
pursuit of their story
um it's nasty stuff and what I think is
has happened and it goes back to kind of
this idea of you know there's now two
playbooks but cancel culture and then
the counter cancer culture uh also in
the media uh space specifically like the
mainstream media has lost like it is
game over game set match it's done
because the audience sizes of where they
chose to build their audience were just
so small compared to the internet and so
what you're seeing now is like if you
went and asked a kid on a college campus
to name the top five information sources
of where they get whether it's political
information you know Finance information
or whatever I'm willing to bet that at
least half right still maybe 50 50 but
at least half are independent type
sources now there's questions like you
know is Jordan Peterson independent
anymore given that he's at uh you know
daily wire and they've got you know
almost a million subscribers like we now
are seeing so much success on the
independent route that it becomes
competitive to some degree uh with the
mainstream but I I don't know do you
agree that most people on college
campuses are actually getting a big
portion of their information from
independent sources or do you still see
most of them going to the mainstream
Outlets oh 100 like I actually I think
it's gone to such a ridiculous extreme
where like you look at the polling and
people are like I'm getting my news from
Tick Tock and Snapchat so it's so
disaggregated that it's not even it's
just like some random person anyways to
take talk about a political thing and
it's like I I don't know I am I think
that's concerning even though I'm I'm
all for Independent disaggregated Media
I think is
I mean definitely all the big guys have
been taken down and the idea that we
would look to one sort of Voice or one
news anchor as like the Arbiter of Truth
on our behalf is very much a thing of
the past which I think in one way is
healthy and another way it's kind of sad
that it used there there is a
journalistic idea that you don't say
your opinions which I'm an opinion
journalist so I don't pretend that I am
I'm not saying what I think but there
was a time and place where a news anchor
would just say here here are the
relevant facts and that's the
journalistic ideal that you don't need
to lead people to a conclusion or pick
and choose which facts are suitable for
them and we've seen that happen
so many times I mean I was just recently
thinking about the New York Post Hunter
Biden laptop Scandal which I wasn't
there for but
um I recently talked to the
editor-in-chief who okayed the story
going through and I mean I can't even
imagine being a part of that Newsroom at
the time when you can't even share it on
Twitter New York Post is locked out of
its Twitter account it's one of the
biggest newspapers in the country and
um yeah I mean I think it's a healthy
thing that we have all kind of found
voices that match us a little bit more
it's also I think there's a consequence
to that which is that we all end up in
our Echo Chambers and it's kind of hard
to hear anyone else anymore but I think
it's definitely better than the model of
like there's the one team kind of media
and the other team kind of media and you
pick your side and then you just talk
past each other forever at least there's
more Nuance now it feels like uh the
divisiveness in media coverage is a
proxy for the divisiveness in politics
and I've seen you argue that uh gen Z
which you may have to Define gen Z for
myself and and uh others but they only
have ever known political divisiveness
like the early parts of their life they
don't know anything about politics and
then they basically walk right into 2016
election and from there you know
explosion over the next six years is
just all out you know competition in a
positive light you know a political war
if you will uh in the most extreme
version
yeah totally I mean I was
probably 15 in the lead up to the 2016
election and 16 when it happened and so
that's the beginning of my political
memory
um I can kind of vaguely remember the
elections before but not with any level
of sophistication I was like 12.
um and so I think there's there's a
shared strange generational experience
with Gen Z which I think is people who
are in 97 to 2012 which I'm I'm really
talking about the people closer to 97 to
like within a few years of my age range
where we've only really non-political
divisiveness we've only known a reality
where like there are relatives that you
can't invite to Thanksgiving because
somebody's mad at somebody else over
politics even though they've been just
fine for decades before that and so I
think growing up with that looking at
that model and looking at okay there are
these two party systems it's literally
like shattering the fabric of of my
school and people are getting canceled
or is shattering the fabric of my my um
my family and my maybe my parents are
having tension because they like the
opposite political party like growing up
with that I think there's there's a
reason why gen Z even though I I would
say that by and large we are very
Progressive
um and definitely on the left but we're
far less likely than most people to say
like ascribe our political beliefs to a
specific party I think it's
um gen Z is twice as likely to be
registered independent as anyone in the
general electorate and so
I would I wouldn't say that means that
we're all a bunch of moderates like
there are Independents who are further
left than Democrats and independents who
are further rate than Republicans among
us but
um there's a general sense that this
system isn't working and that like maybe
a third party I mean I'm I am a fan of
Andrew yangs not every single thing like
I mean he's definitely further left than
I am but I'm a fan of his vision for um
bringing like a third party in or at
least performing some aspects of how our
democracy runs in order to kind of
depolarize and break down the duopoly of
two parties but I would say My
Generation by and large is
um more attracted to that because we've
never known anything different than just
like a partisan hellscape and things cut
like the wheels coming off the the bus
here with our country being torn apart
by these two teams and then every single
election that I remember have just been
lesser of two evil elections where it
doesn't seem like anyone's happy with
the options that we have so
why I mean I'm a registered independent
I don't know why I would uh
put myself in a specific box because of
that life experience
so I'm going to read you three stats uh
that you put in one of your articles and
each one of these I was like oh boy and
the third one really shook me uh
California during the
um runoff uh they saw 48 drop in young
turnout compared to 2020. the Virginia
governor race saw a 62 percent drop in
voters under 30. you know more than 60
percent drop and then the last one was
half of gen Z is registered as
Independence I think that that would
shock people who are older who are used
to Independence was kind of a joke like
you know it's like all Libertarians and
independents they hang out with all
their imaginary friends right and it's
like the Republicans and Democrats and
nobody else what's going on what why do
you think that that is such a high
percentage of uh registered voters
because the systems never worked for us
for as long as we can remember and the
idea that you have two options and that
I mean we're the most diverse generation
of human beings to ever share a nation
in human history and there's absolutely
no reason why we should just fit into
two sets of boxes I think people are um
I mean there's a whole host of
complaints of I know a ton of people who
are Independents because the Democratic
party is not left enough for them so
it's not like we're a bunch of moderates
sitting around in the middle and just
like wanting everyone to be Kumbaya but
um I think just that life experience in
that context has made us way more
independent minded which I think could
in the long term be a good thing
um I mean we're definitely definitely
further like the the mean of my
generation is far more to the left than
I am but
um there's also another interesting
statistic that like the biggest drops of
approval ratings for Biden over the past
couple years have been among young
people in gen Z so
um even though I I there are very few of
us that are registered Republican there
are also very few of us who look and say
like the Democratic parties is doing
what I wanted to do or or like at least
that Biden is and so
um yeah I don't know I think it's just
this new attitude of like George
Washington his Farewell Address was like
don't do the two-party system thing
because that's going to pull people
apart and alienate them from one another
and here's the generation whose whole
life experience is
um kind of built on that foundation and
that understanding all right so Andrew
Yang's got this new uh political party
uh the Ford party uh when I first heard
about it I was like there's zero percent
chance that the Republicans and
Democrats are gonna let anyone else in
the game just they will do anything and
everything they possibly can to stop
that what is the general idea behind the
Ford parts so like structurally yes
there should be a third party okay we're
gonna go try to do that what are like
the main points of the Ford party
yeah so um I'm definitely not an expert
on it but I have looked into it quite a
bit and he so he had a lot of like
personal policies that he's kind of put
on the back burner now that he's merged
with um like two small Republican party
offshoots as well
um so he's not he's no longer through
the party platform advocating for
Universal basic income which I know is
what Emily needed a lot of people from
his platform yeah I'm out on that just
so we're clear I'm out on the Ubi I
think it's the dumbest idea person
either
um definitely not but I he basically the
party right now I don't believe they're
running candidates but what they're
doing because like there's this whole
like legitimate narrative that if
somebody is running as a third party
candidate it's the spoiler effect that
either your
throwing away your Vote or you're giving
a vote taking away a boat from the party
that you would prefer between the two
options and so they're acknowledging
that that's a problem in our system
right now and they're not trying to run
people to just like ruin elections and
get people elected that wouldn't
otherwise
um so they're endorsing people
regardless of their political
affiliation so you could be a Democrat a
Republican or an independent that just
shares values of like wanting some more
cohesion and believing in like
cross-party cooperation and
um like a lot of values that I think are
just fundamental to a democracy that
we've lost sight of but a few of his
reforms I really like which one of them
is like open part open partisan
primaries so
in the beginning phases of an election
rather than have people like the most
extreme voters that are actually
motivated enough to go and they're
registered for their party and they're
going to go get up an extra day and vote
for a candidate within that party and
then have the two extremes phase off
against each other he wants to open it
up to make it that the app like every
voter can vote for any candidate and
then the two best people end up facing
off which seems to me like a better way
to get at the mean of what people
actually want in a candidate and he was
also advocated for ranked Choice voting
which would do kind of a similar thing
like you don't have to pick an extreme
and then if your voice doesn't get heard
on one thing it can get hurt on the next
and so it kind of averages out to the
collective will which I think in New
York City that was how Eric Adams ended
up getting elected and that's a
demonstration of the fact that like I
mean I don't think he's been doing as
great of a job as I had hoped but that a
more moderate candidate can rise to the
top through the process of kind of
averaging out people as well and so I'm
I'm into a few of his ideas there but I
don't know what are your thoughts yeah I
I think that there's a number of
different ideas uh he's got the ranked
Choice voting uh I think it's open
primary is another one
um that they're like very nuanced
structural things in the U.S political
process with if you don't pay attention
to politics you don't even know what
this stuff means right so it's like you
really got to understand what the
problems are to understand what the
potential Solutions are and it seems
like he's done that uh I'm definitely
out on the Ubi uh for reasons that you
know people may or may not agree with
but the Ubi thing
um I understand and I'm sympathetic to
the problem that has been identified
right like uh I was just reading an
article today uh Northwestern Mutual
just did a brand new study uh for 2021
um that they just now are publishing and
they were talking about retirement and
in the retirement uh study it said that
Americans are reporting they need 1.25
million dollars to retire that is up 20
from 1.08 million which was what they
reported in 2020. so it's a 20 leap in
what they think that they need but the
problem is the average and retirement
age went from I think it was like 62.6
you know years old to now 64. so we've
increased the retirement age we think we
need 20 more money but the actual amount
of money people have saved has dropped
11 percent went from like 98 000 to like
86 000 or whatever the exact numbers are
and so you look at that and you're like
oh people are screwed like there's no
math you can't you know come up with
some like nice slick way to talk about
it it's like you need 1.25 million which
I would actually actually low but you
need 1.25 million to retire you only
have less than 100K uh it's not clear
how you're going to close that Gap and
by the way you've got to work longer to
even get to the 100K number and so like
this is a bad situation what's the
solution well somebody steps in is like
let's just give people money I get it I
I understand why that is a potential
answer
but the problem with it is exactly what
we just saw for the last you know almost
three years now which is when the
government steps in and starts handing
out free money they screw everything up
and they don't mean to do it it's just
you cannot continue to intervene in a
free market and do it now do we have
free markets in the United States it's
pretty obvious no uh but if they
continue to intervene like this what it
does is it actually hurts over the long
term and obviously the high inflation
now but you can imagine if all of a
sudden we were given a thousand dollars
to everyone every single month uh it'd
be a bad situation and so when you look
at this what It ultimately goes back to
and I think where a lot of people maybe
this is some of the independent stuff is
like the problem seem to be pretty well
identified it actually I think that is a
point of agreement across uh political
lines it's like people are like oh crime
is bad you know oh inflation is bad oh
this you know uh retirement situation is
bad it's the potential Solutions where
all the disagreements are and so you
know maybe we counted as a win that we
all agree on the problems but maybe not
I don't know
is it okay X the new race car maybe but
actually no okay X is one of the world's
leading crypto trading apps okay X
yeah yeah I don't know I mean I
definitely agree with you on the Ubi
front
um I have the only time that I've kind
of been sympathetic to it is hearing him
argue it in the sense that rats like
this would be in place of a welfare
system and rather than what we're doing
right now which is giving people money
and filtering it through a bunch of
bureaucracies and paying salaries of
people that don't really need to be
there in the first place and then giving
people money to do a specific thing with
it is a much more convoluted and
ridiculous system than just trusting
people with money and saying here do
what you want with it and there's like
an additional level of freedom but I
also just kind of reject the assumption
that the welfare state is necessarily A
a like a reality of our country even
though it is right now I I think fixing
it by making it just a different version
isn't really where I would like to see
the country go but um to your question
about whether seeing problems or seeing
the same problems but having different
solutions is a good thing or a bad thing
I mean I think
it just it's not even relevant anymore
in my opinion because we're not even
like we're just talking so far past each
other that even though we are trying to
solve the same problems and we we do
like you you can look at like the War on
Drugs versus like the decriminalization
efforts right now which I think some of
them have gone way too far even though
I'm generally
um understanding that the war on drugs
and criminalizing people who are in
terrible situations in the first place
isn't the best solution like both those
parties even though that's the opposite
reaction to the same problem looked at
people who were suffering from drug
addiction and look looked at people who
are who are living on the streets and
tripping out and said this is a problem
that we need to solve and it's awful and
here's my best version of doing it but I
think we've just gone so far to an
extreme where we're not even hearing
each other and realizing like our hearts
are in the same place just our minds are
going somewhere different and I mean
anything to actually get some
conversation and some compromise between
these two polar extremes that we have
right now if it's the forward party if
it's just like inculcating the ideals of
democracy and free speech and pluralism
in public schools and teaching kids what
that means to be a citizen and a
responsible citizen in a democracy like
whatever we can do to get to the point
where
we can recognize again that we are
solving the same issues we all want life
to be better for people we all have
different ideas and maybe just fighting
about our two different versions Ad
nauseam and never getting anywhere and
gridlock is not the solution and
figuring out if there is some sort of
moderation or compromise or
um kind of letting the marketplace of
ideas do get out a little more than it
actually does right now would be a
positive thing but I don't think the
fact that our hearts are all in the
right places helping right now because
we don't even really realize that or
acknowledge it capitalism is the best
jobs program
is just like a it's a way that I always
just come back to like yes there's all
kinds of great ideas but at the end of
the day if you want to create jobs like
encourage capitalism right encourage
small medium-sized businesses encourage
the founding of companies like allow for
the incentives to take over and that is
a very specific example around jobs but
I think that you can take that exact
same mentality and Viewpoint and kind of
bring it to these other issues and what
you realize is that uh the United States
like we got a hell of a lot of problems
but there's not a better system than a
democratic capitalistic system like if
we saw another one we might try it but
but I don't see one out there and so it
feels like that really kind of hammers
home like maybe we should just focus on
uh kind of encouraging the the benefits
of that approach uh because it's gotten
us to this place and we don't yet see
something that's better
yeah I mean I completely agree with that
and I'm very libertarian in my
orientation especially around three
markets and you know it's it's like it's
something that I've been thinking about
a lot is like I think there's an idea
that capitalism is this terrible system
because what we're looking at is
actually like a crony capitalist system
that isn't functioning as it's meant to
and we've increasingly intruded on it
and then needed to kind of fix things on
the back end and just dug ourselves
deeper and deeper in but I'm wondering I
mean I don't know a ton about it but I
was I was listening to a lot of people
saying that like what happened in
England with Liz trust was like the
proof that the libertarian concept is
not a great thing and that you can't
just like cut taxes and cut spending and
just hope that everything works out and
I think her experimentation there seems
to have proven that to be true under the
system that we have right now I wonder
like if if we were to go down more of
like a deregulation route how do we
untangle ourselves from all the areas of
society that are dependent on the fact
that we've moved so far away from that I
don't know do you have a take on the Liz
trust thing uh not necessarily on Liz
trust specifically I think just on on
the broader point you know one of the
biggest problems uh across all economies
in societies right now is the debt to
GDP ratios and so when you look you know
in the US for 13140 globally around 400
uh percent or so and
part of the problem is that when people
talk about this they only focus on the
debt side so there's obviously the
raising of the debt limits and uh kind
of the constant should the government
print more money should the government
do this should the government do that uh
and when you look at that from a debt
perspective that then leads to this
question of like oh well how do we get
more taxes right and the taxes just
Revenue to help pay for some of these
sins but the part of the conversation to
me that's the most interesting is like
how the hell do we grow out of the
problem and now you know GDP growth in
the United States is you know if we're
lucky two to three percent uh a year
um it's been negative obviously for the
first half of uh of 2022 which is a
recession even though some may say it's
not
um but in order for us to go out of this
like we need to grow at like 10 a year
pretty hard to do right but it doesn't
mean that it is impossible so I always
come back to this idea of like yes we
should focus on the debt side of the
equation but also we should focus on the
growth side and so if you look at you
know uh her specific situation where
they're cutting taxes and doing this
stuff the Nuance is like well what taxes
are being cut what is the incentive that
is actually being driven here and if
that was going to over a five-year
period lead to you know uh great
economic expansion and job creation and
economic value that leads to more taxes
and you know this whole like kind of
chain reaction great but if it to your
point is more like a crony capitalism
type system where it's just like hey
let's go find all the rich people and
give them tax breaks so they can just
sit on their money and they don't have
to pay taxes I think a lot of people
like that that's probably not the the
right way to do it And So It ultimately
gets at is if we gave a very simple
economic test to politicians like
economics 101
I don't know what percent would pass
like over under 50 of the Senate and
Congress in the United States passes a
economics 101 test
I fear that it is less than 50 percent
yeah right totally and some of the
loudest voices in that front I think are
the most removed from actual economic
reality is like I mean gas station
owners or terrorists in America right
now like like literally right it's like
hey why won't they bring the gas prices
down or if you look at the grocery
stores like they're price gouging I mean
these are things that serious
politicians have levied against people
who I think the grocery store industry
operates on less than a five percent
profit margin
right and I think that they have been
able to survive literally when the
government was ordering businesses to
shut down thankfully left them open
um but you look at this and you just
start to say yourself like they can't be
serious they can't be trying to solve
the problems this has to be campaigning
this has to be a uh effort to remain in
their position of power and influence
rather than actually solve some of these
problems
because if you're yelling at the gas
station owners like I I I think we're
just like past the point of seriousness
yeah I mean the level of deflection on
economics recently and like I mean some
of the shocking arguments being made
that it's like all of a sudden corporate
greed is what's causing inflation
because corporations just decided in
2022 that they would like some more
money like it's it's shocking it's also
like I I went to really great schools I
got I got a great education I went to a
boarding school in high school I was
taught so many of the same things over
and over and over again I know way too
much about like Chinese and Indian
history for some reason and I was taught
that like three separate years in my
school and I never was made to take an
economics class which is really
interesting to me or even just like a
basic like here's not even at a national
level but like here's what a check is
and here is how you like can budget out
your spending and here's the I mean just
the very basics of how to be an adult
were never taught the very basics of how
our economy Works we're never taught
unless you specifically sought that out
and like even coming out of NYU and
doing two years there the only reason
that I've ever taken an economics
process because I specifically had to
like take a class outside of my program
to do as an elective which I'm so glad
that I did because there were so many
very fundamental things that I'm
embarrassed in retrospect that I didn't
really understand and were never taught
to me and it's amazing to me so so many
so many things that are so relevant to
our day-to-day life like even just like
nutrition and you know you eat three
meals a day and it would probably be a
good thing if the school system rather
than teaching us like pre-algebra or
like trigonometry or something that I
mean if you're gonna go down to math
field please by all means take that
class but the idea that we're gonna like
short circuit kids knowledge about
things that are very important and very
pertinent to their day-to-day lives like
economics with nutrition and not value
education about that is just shocking
like I think the level of ignorance on
it on the economic front is
unbelievable and the only reason that I
think some politicians certainly do know
better but they they realize that saying
the convenient thing that corporations
are suddenly greedy today is what's
going to get votes and attention because
it's it's the bad guy that you can point
your fingers at rather than pointing
your finger at the politician who
created inflationary policies and so um
that ignorance from our education system
is being preyed upon by politicians in
my opinion it's still transitory don't
worry it is 100 transitory
I think there's like the memory holding
of the whole idea that like oh yeah no
that never really happened like even
with a lot of covid policies like
there's a general shift towards
pragmatism or a general shift towards
acknowledging that inflation might be
caused by spending but then we kind of
just like are supposed to forget all the
things that happened before and all the
other stances that people had in the
past I don't know if you've had that
impression too but it's it's kind of
interesting or like even deep on the
police like you have politicians who
were at the very least playing into that
narrative if not explicitly saying it
who now we're like oh no we're pro cop
like what are you talking about I don't
remember that there is
um a number of people that I've seen
give speeches recently who are like
we've known the entire time that not
having children be in person for
Education would stunt their educational
you know whatever and it's like uh that
doesn't seem like that was the narrative
you know two years ago uh the thing that
I'm watching and you know there's a
little bit of a moving Target because it
just happened uh but I'm interested in
your thoughts so New York's Supreme
Court I believe uh yesterday or the day
before came out with a ruling uh that
stated any employee in the state of New
York who was fired for not being
vaccinated has to be reinstated to their
job and given back pay now I read
through maybe 20 minutes yesterday and
it appears that this is not the final
say this is yes a ruling but there's an
appeals process and so we don't know
exactly where it'll end up
what's your take on this so far of like
that's a pretty damning uh conclusion if
that ends up standing
for what's played out over the last you
know two three years
do you know is it it's I assume it's
just city employees or public employees
uh that's a great question I'll get you
that answer in a second okay yeah sorry
I haven't done my research on on this
latest update I just saw the headline
a few minutes ago I've been underwater
writing my book so I forget the real
world is happening
um but yeah I I was I've been following
the mandates closely as they've been
coming out as a New York City resident
I've like just disgusted by the way that
the vaccine mandates were rolled out
here personally but um I mean I think if
I assume that just applies to public
employees and I think that's certainly
the right move I mean I spoke recently
to the head of one of the major fire
department unions here and
um just to get a sense of like what what
people are thinking about they like I
think they were upholding the Mandate
and then they just lifted it for private
sector employees only and not public
sector employees so basically everyone
was allowed to go back to work if they
weren't vaccinated except for public
sector employees which includes police
officers and and firemen who were
precisely the people who during the
worst wave of the pan endemic had no
choice but to expose themselves to covid
were continuing to go out on the front
lines most of them got it in the process
and recovered and you know there's
questions about how long natural
immunity lasts but certainly it's a
thing that they have the right to claim
or even if like I mean they've just all
been exposed 100 and they were the
people who were made to meet the
creative sacrifices and then there's
this vaccine mandate that is now only
applying to them and they've had so many
I was I spoke to the Union uh head who
said they've had so many more
retirements than
um like typically in that period of time
and that very many of them it just said
like I just I don't want to get
vaccinated and this isn't the way that I
I want to continue working here like I'm
out I'm leaving it's just so
ridiculously unjust the way that that
things have unfolded here and the idea
that uh local government officials who
have no Health Public Health background
like Bill de Blasio medical decision for
a ton of people including young people
who it turns out some of them like young
men might actually be at greater risk of
myocarditis as an adverse effect but we
didn't know that yet but Bill de Blasio
decided that he could make them get
vaccinated if they want to go to a gym
or eat at a restaurant or just exist in
the city I mean it's that that's
certainly if that I mean what I I'm all
for reversing that and giving people the
respect and dignity that they deserve to
make that choice for themselves
so the court uh found it is for
government employees there's about 1400
or so uh who are fired for being
unvaccinated earlier this year uh it was
a policy or a mandate that was uh
established under Bill de Blasio uh and
I guess mayor Eric Adams claimed that
they would not rehire those employees so
de Blasio and stated it and Eric Adams
essentially looks like he has said hey
we're going to continue this and not
rehire the 1400 people that we fired
um the court there's two interesting
Parts one the reinstation uh
reinstatement of all employees
um and they have to get back pay but the
second thing is it explicitly said this
is a direct quote being vaccinated does
not prevent an individual from
Contracting or transmitting covid-19 end
quote and so what becomes fascinating
about this is I just read that that is
from the New York Supreme Court in the
back of my head I am thinking there's a
50 50 shot whether YouTube is going to
tell me we violated their policies
hmm right yeah there's a 50 50 shot
whether videos will get taken down
whether conversations will be removed
for stating a direct quote of what a
court a judge has said which he is
basing on what the CDC is now saying
wow and so when you get into this world
what you start to realize is like
truth used to be very black and white
it has now become there is truth and
then there is what The Gatekeepers
whether that's mainstream media whether
that's the platforms or anything else
want the truth to be
and those two things sometimes align and
sometimes they don't which is kind of a
crazy thing to be living in a world
where it's very obvious that they are
two separate things that may or may not
be in agreement with each other yeah
totally I mean there there have been so
many examples of that the New York Post
story that turned out to be true and
then there's just like the quiet little
admission that like oh yeah maybe that
laptop that was fine we didn't actually
have to Center you all off Twitter and
and remove that and yeah like all the
all the increasing Revelations about
kovid that were once misinformation or
like the the lab League Theory which is
certainly very implausible if not likely
now which used to be uh relegated to the
Dustbin but I would say actually I
wouldn't say that truth used to be more
black and white I think we used to have
a different understanding of what like
The Pursuit Of Truth meant because
obviously there are things that we
believed that are totally untrue and we
look back on some like scientific facts
or medical uh practices that we might
have done like bloodletting and we're
like okay like that was their version of
black and white truth but it's certainly
not true now and we know that and we've
progressed but I think we've lost touch
with like the idea of epistemic humility
and like the concept that we don't know
every everything and the whole reason
that we're wrestling with ideas and
having conversations and talking about
things is because we all want to get
closer to truth and the only way that we
can do that is by letting ideas play out
by acknowledging that it isn't black and
white that it's something that we're
striving towards that right now we're
certainly saying things and doing things
and believing things that people in the
future are going to look back on and say
oh that was wrong or that was ridiculous
or that was immoral and I think we used
to acknowledge that there's no one
Arbiter of Truth and there's no like one
gatekeeper that can say this is fact and
this is fiction and we've drifted so far
away from the idea that we need to let
people duke it out and and have
conversations and express themselves
that we've just assigned these arbitrary
institutions like social media companies
or journalists that none of us have even
heard the names of to decide that like
this is what you can see and this is
what you can't see and it's it's really
shocking I mean and I can't even I I
think you're probably right on on the
front of like reading something like
that might violate their policies which
is just shocking and the idea that that
would even be there in the first place
or that we would entrust
a company that like isn't a public
health entity or let alone a public
health entity to decide what is true and
what is false I mean California has
um some crazy new licensing law that
they rolled out for medical
professionals that says that
um like misinformation or giving a a
patient misinformation about covid could
lead to losing their license but there
are so many things that are now known
and accepted information pieces about
covid that were once misinformation so
um yeah I completely agree it's it's
just it's shocking how arbitrary it is
that we just
decide that these certain institutions
can can choose what is appropriate for
people to be thinking about and
wrestling with and talking about
do we have a mental toughness crisis in
America like so much of this feels like
people are offended people are uh
somewhat weak-minded uh uh they have
very little intellectual rigor in their
thinking is it just like kind of come
back to hey if we could teach people to
be mentally tough we'd be better off as
a society
I mean I kind of think so yeah I think
one of the most damaging
things that has happened or like ideas
that has risen up is that like words are
harmful
um and that's something that we we very
carefully legally put like the fence
around of like these very specific
things are harmful like defamation and
direct incitement of violence and
virtually nothing else that you can't
say because we have a First Amendment
for a good reason and I think that like
this there's just this general idea that
that exposure to different ideas is
something that can endanger you and I
think also
um especially in my generation I see
this all the time with I think like the
locus of control is moved where we're no
longer telling people like how like yeah
the world is shitty and unjust and
terrible things happen and people end up
in different situations and and some
people have to climb up the ladder a
whole lot higher just to get to the
point where someone else started and
that's that's we can't change I mean
obviously we can make policies to
ameliorate that fact but we can't change
that reality for people in in right here
and right now and the only thing that
they can do is assume responsibility and
pull themselves up by the bootstraps
despite the circumstances and not like
there's no there's no value to pointing
to this and that of course identify the
systems that are holding you down and
advocate for reform but the idea that
you can't do stuff for yourself that
like the victim mentality rather than
the individualistic like
like self self-oriented sort of like I I
can only control what I do and so
therefore I'm going to make my actions
as good and intentional and productive
and hardworking as possible I think that
attitude is also a major issue
um but yeah I would say
like just the idea like there's just a
lack of
um like self-motivation and a value that
our society has placed on the more kind
of points of victimhood that you can say
and I mean even being in like classrooms
recently in a college like you'd hear so
many points start with as a woman or as
a member of the LGBT community and like
you need to like
kind of virtue signal that you're a part
of something that has been pulled down
and I think that's just the most
fundamentally backwards way of thinking
about the world and thinking about how
you can make your life better if you're
just looking at Broad systems and you
lose sight of yourself and the actions
that are in your own control I think
that's a really dangerous thing I also
think that's what Peterson is kind of
saying and it shouldn't be
um such a terrible idea to be espousing
to young people to just drive some
empowerment from themselves but um I
think that kind of all goes into this
idea that we need to be protected from
ideas we need these institutions to
decide what is real and what is false
because we can't be trusted to do it
ourselves which is really really sad I
don't know what's your take on that what
how do you feel about the mental
toughness oh I think it's a huge problem
um you know and look I I uh I grew up in
a family of five boys I was in the
military like I've got like the most
extreme you know version of uh that
there just was no room for uh much else
at this same time I don't think that it
should be expected like we should take
everybody and like send them to the
military uh I don't think that we should
uh like indoctrinate them into you know
Jocko will Nick's uh like School of you
know Hard Knocks or anything like that
um but I do think that uh there is
um responsibility that lays with parents
I think is a huge issue
um you know I I've said many times
before like how many of our societal
problems could be solved if we had uh
better parents I don't know what the
percentage is it's impossible to measure
but just like it does feel like there's
um you know a lot of people I've got a
lot of friends that are having kids now
and stuff and like the conversation's
all like dude I'm unprepared for this
the guy I don't know what to do right
and so like again like what's the
solution I don't know like are we gonna
like put young adults through like
parent training ah that feels like
that's probably unscalable and unlikely
and then you get in a whole debate of
like what should be taught what
shouldn't whatever but just like there
is some connection between you know you
learn uh ethos and ethics and certain
things from people
um that are older than you specifically
your parents as well and so like there's
something there the second thing is uh
we should make sure that people are
offended earlier in their life we should
put them in tough situations right and
not because we want to harm them uh but
actually for the opposite because we
love them because we want them to be
able to withstand whatever the world
throws at them in the future
um and so it feels like by the the
coddling and and kind of
um the the prevention of anything bad
happening we actually are doing more
long-term damage than we are a kind of
long-term benefit
and then there's this element also of
just like the best ideas come from like
the the combat the war of ideas and
attrition and and all these things that
we know work why are we not forcing the
people who want to engage again if you
want to be an artist and you don't want
to participate in an intellectual debate
or or talk about you know certain topics
like fine do whatever you want to do uh
but for the people who do want to engage
in this stuff uh rather than coddle them
like put them in the arena and I think
that what would end up happening is they
would get offended but they would become
better at form ending uh forming their
ideas at being able to defend their
ideas at understanding the other side
like that's one of the things that
always cracks me up is you know I'll
talk to a friend and they'll be like I
can't believe you know ABC thing you
know about some topic about the current
thing and I'd be like cool you ever talk
to anyone that believes like the
opposite
they're not no
you got a lot of opinions and they seem
pretty strongly held about this thing
that you only have your perspective on
like you have no clue what the other
side thinks about this and so it's um
it's hard right it's uncomfortable uh it
requires a degree of uh intellectual
honesty but also just like
paint like a paint threshold nobody
wants to be told that their ideas are
wrong right nobody wants to go and seek
out and have a conversation with someone
who's like you're dumb but like maybe
that's what we need maybe that would
actually push us forward as a society is
to like go do the uncomfortable hard
things
yeah totally I mean
there have been so many interests
on this
to need to kind of chip away at yourself
in order to build it back in a better
and stronger sense and I think the
parenting is a huge thing here in my
opinion
um a friend of mine Lenoir scanizi like
founded this movement called the free
range kids movement which is not
actually that crazy and revolutionary an
idea it's just like like treating kids
how we did just a couple Generations ago
or even a couple decades ago not even a
couple Generations ago where you let
your kids go outside you let them scrape
their knee you let them go and play on
their own you don't need to bring them
to uh piano lessons in order to keep
them them like active you let them go in
and play pretend and screw up and fall
out of a tree and grow and develop and
build like build themselves in an
independent way you don't you know you
you don't ask your kid to help bake
something with you and then do
everything for them and and crack the
eggs and stuff like you let kids
actually mess up and fumble and develop
up and grow and go outside and you don't
have to cuddle them and protect them and
be a helicopter over them and I think
that like raising a whole generation
like that has had serious consequences
because people need their hands held now
like with their professors even like
I've heard from people who lead
companies who say I've hired these young
kids they just graduated from college to
answer problems and to solve things and
now they're coming to me and they're
asking me like how do I solve this
problem or what should I do or how
should I attack this and it's like well
that's your job but unfortunately this
is what happens when you have professors
who are saying well here's how you write
the assignment and you have parents who
say oh I'll do that for you don't worry
you don't have to bother yourself to do
that like I I can protect you or I'll
I'll pave the jungle for you and make
sure that everything is okay and you
have I think it's it's important good
intentions to make life easier for kids
but we've just totally short-circuited
like self-development and I I've seen
the consequences personally
um I I think again having like an older
parent was super helpful to that because
my dad's like I remember World War II
like I don't really want to hear about
that you're offended like it's fine
um so
yeah I even wonder
um like the Next Generation I think will
be even worse of the kids who grew up
with like iPads and plugged into
um technology and like this alternative
world and never even really went out and
explored it all period let alone
um explored in a way that built some
fortitude and some Independence but I
don't know have you like I've like
people that you know had this iPad kid
conversation oh yeah yeah I I've got a
uh I've got a daughter uh a bunch of my
friends have you know kids under the age
of
um I don't know 10 years old or so uh
and the three things that everyone uh
discusses not everyone agrees on what
the solution is but it's like you know
Electronics uh how much time in front of
it or what do they do uh the second
thing is
um my version of describing it is like
what happens if your kid can just act
ask Alexa what the math problem is and
you know get an answer what if they can
like use AI to like write their essay
like are we just gonna have like stupid
people who who are actually going to be
skilled if they can just use the tools
um but like that that's kind of a weird
thing and then third thing frankly is
um do you send your kids to school and
this is like a taboo topic but like
I don't know I gotta I got a ways to go
my daughter's only about one years old
so I I got some time to kind of change
my mind learn more whatever but like
there is zero chance my daughter's going
to a regular school where you don't know
what's happening forget like what the
extreme you know kind of examples we've
heard of the stories where it's you know
this thing happened people like how
could we let that happen or this other
thing or the reading this book or
whatever
the bigger thing to me is just you have
no clue what is happening inside that
school and we now are hearing stories
where the school is actively telling
parents one thing and they're doing
something else
and so it's like growing up in a world
where myself you many people who are
listening to this we had some increase
of transparency into things that our
parents or grandparents didn't have so
we have Google we understand that
there's reporting like like there's all
these things that occur and things like
Twitter Etc gave us access to
information faster or whatever I
actually think it scares the [ __ ] out of
us to be like Oh I'm going to send a
child to a place where I actually don't
know what happens inside of that school
I can't you know put up cameras there's
no like uh uh Twitter feed that's live
covering what's going on in the school
that day like it literally is a black
hole to some degree and so I think for
young parents
um there's a lot more questions than
answers which you know at least they're
talking about it maybe it's like the
positive way to look at it but at the
same time like
maybe our parents and our grandparents
have the same problem maybe they were
like you know hey I got to get my kid
into a good school so they don't go to
this other school that's like you know
teaching crazy stuff I I don't know but
it just feels like
um that's not very well covered right
now in the media but a lot of young
parents are sitting there saying like
what do we do and I don't think it's
clear answer
yeah definitely I mean I can only
imagine if I had a kid right now I'd be
thinking about the same thing but I mean
I just don't feel like it used to be as
big of a problem I mean I also don't
think people have the luxury of thinking
about it but the idea that politics
would in any way be involved with
especially young children or that not I
mean obviously there's like very basic
politics of like these are our common
values as a nation but the idea that
some like partisan controversial not cut
and dry clear political motives would be
coming out on by teachers on children on
impressionable children I think is
something that
um you know I I think 2020 clarified it
for people but I saw it rise myself I
never felt that way when I was a kid
growing up and going to school and then
sometime around like 2014 2015 was the
first time that it's like okay some
things something's clearly political
here and I'm not being like I'm not
being told the whole truth in a sense um
like I remember my freshman year of high
school on MLK day it was a boarding
school so they didn't want to let kids
have like long weekends where they'd go
to New York City or like do something
stupid because they're responsible for
them and so they kept us busy with like
activities that day and they on MLK Day
split us up by Affinity groups which is
I know not like such a shocking thing
anymore because we hear these stories
all the time of kids getting split up by
race to talk about race in different
different rooms and that's just kind of
a thing that happens but that happened
in 2015 or 2014 whenever I was in school
at that point and that was like one of
the earliest iterations of something
like that which I remember at the time
was shocking to me on MLK day that I'd
be in a different building from kids and
basically just undermine the idea of
common Humanity in the first place and I
remember there was some push back at my
school which now has gone like totally
down that route where it's
um that's just like it's so politically
stream but this was the first kind of
intrusion that I ever felt and I
remember a lot of alumni and parents
were upset that that had happened and so
I watched it become more and more
politically extreme during my time in
school and I I mean I was never that
sort of thing or the idea that like a
teacher in my K-8 schooling would ever
be like overtly political without at the
very least saying like this is my
political opinion and people feel
another way is totally foreign to me and
so I think that parents right now are
dealing with a totally novel situation
I'm so grateful that I was insulated
from that in my more formative years and
by the time I ran into those sorts of
things where it was just blatant
indoctrination and political tilt in my
education I was old enough to at the
very least say this doesn't feel right
and I'm gonna remain mindful of it
um I mean I I can't even imagine being a
parent right now I mean homeschooling is
not an easy thing to do and requires a
huge amount of sacrifice and dedication
and the idea that there are people who
feel like there isn't even a suitable
school option for them is so sad like I
work for Megan Kelly and she left the
city because her her kids at all like
she had some at all girls schools and
all boys schools and all of them had
terrible experiences and they ended up
moving up to Connecticut at a school
that they feel is better aligned with
them but it's like the question
shouldn't even be is my school aligned
with me you know I don't know are you
leaning one way or another with your
daughter in terms of school or just
gonna
leave we're chilling I I'm gonna wait
and see mode the only thing um that I
feel pretty strongly about in terms of
educating of young kids is like the
single most important thing you can
teach them uh there's many important
things but like probably the single most
important it's just to be a good
decision maker yeah right and it applies
to everything from all the politics and
kind of crazy culture War controversy
stuff to literally just like what food
do you eat who do you hang out with you
know what uh industry you choose to do
uh every single thing you do if you have
good decision making ability uh I feel
like you can kind of level up your life
the hard part is like how do you teach a
kid that right and and so uh uh I
haven't figured that out yet
um but but I do think uh if you can help
them be a good decision maker then like
that that's half the battle or some you
know material percent
um but the school thing is weird and
there's a lot of young people who are
talking about it and you know I mean you
mentioned Megan Kelly is like a great
example where uh they're willing to move
now I think previously people were a
little less like uh they felt and they
felt strongly enough about it to take
action maybe they sent a letter to the
teacher or they went met with the
principal or whatever I was like hey
stop you know knocking off type stuff
but now that you have people like
actually moving with their feet and uh
with schools boarding schools a lot of
stuff like moving with their dollars
that feedback is is pretty strong if uh
you know if you're watching uh your uh
attendance inside of a private school
dropped by 10 percent
that that's a material hit right and and
so you start to pay attention to that
stuff Public Schools obviously uh are a
little bit different there's people
trying to do different things there so I
don't know it's worth paying attention
to though and I think that uh the way
that you're thinking about it is
probably right that uh people are going
to you know this can become a bigger
Topic in the future
yeah totally I mean it's the youngin
effect down in Virginia like it can win
an election probably more or less
looking at that and I think it's a good
and healthy thing that parents are
taking more ownership over their kids
educational paths I think it's a sad
thing that they have to and that they
feel like they can't trust teachers and
I think that for the most part most
teachers can be trusted and are people
operating in good faith but the sad
thing is that there are some a very a
minority that are highly ideological and
if your kid ends up in a class like that
like that can be confusing and and
traumatizing and I I mean coming home
and feeling like you like values that
you have at home are not reflected in
the teacher that you look up to and
admire or that the teacher that you look
up to and admirer saying that the things
that your family believes and your
family's values are bad or wrong or
backwards or who they voted for is the
wrong person it's just a really a really
sad thing but I I mean I give parents
credit and I give you credit for like
wanting to make sure that that's not
something that that happens to your kids
but it is a really really tough thing
like I went to this awesome K-8 school
that I I loved and I have so many
friends from there still and I was so
sad I heard the other day from people
that
um like they were they were just the
best values as a school I had a great
experience and then I heard that parents
are pulling their kids from that school
as well because it went totally off the
deep end and they have like a Dei
um thing and they're talking about
potentially doing Affinity groups with
with kids who are still in elementary
school like it's it's really sad that
even the institutions that I thought
like oh maybe one day I'll send my kids
there are also falling to the Wayside
here but hopefully the market pressure
and like in the public schools the
voting pressure with school boards will
help sort this out and parents leaving
from private school as well too but
um one can only hope I guess it remains
to be the same absolutely Ricky I really
enjoyed talking with you uh I feel like
we could talk for hours uh if people
want to follow up with you where can
they read some of the stuff that you're
putting out uh at New York Post and then
also follow you on Twitter
yeah um so my handle on Twitter is just
Ricky schlot my name and I tend to post
most of my neighbor posts up there um so
all the important stuff will end up
there and then I also co-host a podcast
um called The Lost debate podcast I'm
the resident libertarian and my co-host
is a former Obama stopper and we try to
have good faith Pleasant debates and
figure out if we can find some common
ground so those are my two main
platforms that people can find me on
awesome thank you so much for uh taking
the time to do this and we'll definitely
do it again in the future yeah totally
thanks for having me